[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
welcome to the waimakariri district
council's three waters reform online
event
we were originally planning to have a
range of in-person events across the
district but of course in levels three
and four that's not possible
so we appreciate you joining us here
online
by now you should have received this in
your letterbox and information regarding
the government's proposal and what it
could mean for the waimakariri district
we'd encourage you to have a good read
and give us your feedback either on the
form or online at our let's talk site
our let's talk page is the easiest way
for you to have your say on matters in
waimakariri that will affect you
visit
waimakariri.govt dot nz forward slash
let's talk to get started here you'll
find all the issues that council is
currently wanting feedback on
once you sign up and select the topics
that interest you you can even turn on
notifications for when a new
consultation opens
each page has a wealth of information
and resources for you to delve into you
can ask questions from our staff
subscribe to project updates and once
you're ready you can easily send us your
feedback using the online survey
so if you haven't already make sure you
visit our let's talk site and have your
say
tonight we're joined by a panel that
will answer any questions you might have
about the proposed reform or the
council's water services here in
waimakariri
i'm going to ask them to introduce
themselves and we'll start with mayor
dan
good evening i'm dan gordon mayor of
waimakariri it's great to be here and
thanks to all who have joined
tonight to find out about this important
issue for our district i also want to
acknowledge the councillors of the
present listening to this live stream
tonight thanks nicola
thank you mia jim would like would you
like to go next
hey cura and good evening everybody i'm
jim harland the chief executive i've
been with the council since
early april and i'm looking forward to
assisting the the panel to answer your
questions
great thanks jim and finally we have
jared
hello everybody i'm jared cleary i'm the
manager of utilities and roading at the
waimakariri council so yeah looking
forward to help answer questions tonight
great thanks jared tonight we'll be
submitting your questions live to the
panel so if you do have a question about
the three audits reform enter it in the
comments or in the chat box and we'll
put it to the panel shortly
before we get to the questions let's
take a very quick overview of the
proposed three waters reform and see
what it's all about
you may have seen that the council is
asking waimakariri residents for their
views on the government's proposed three
waters reform
the government is proposing that three
water services that's drinking water
waste water and storm water move from
the 67 councils who currently manage
these into four large entities
if the reform goes ahead waimakariri's
water services would become part of an
entity that covers most of the south
island
the government has given councils until
the end of september to provide feedback
on the proposal
before the council makes a decision
about the next stage of the reform
process we're keen to hear what our
community thinks
the fundamental question is will the
reform proposal benefit the waimakariri
community
we all agree that quality drinking water
and environmental outcomes are a good
thing for the country
but at the moment it's not clear whether
the proposed reforms are the best way to
achieve this and what the advantages are
for our district
the government has five main concerns
affordability
in some parts of new zealand it's
becoming unaffordable for smaller
councils to provide safe and reliable
drinking water
consistency of water quality
there is a difference in water quality
and security around new zealand
under investment in some parts of new
zealand there are large costs on the
horizon to meet new drinking water
standards
the ability to meet future requirements
with new economic and water regulators
there is concern councils won't be able
to meet future requirements
and resilience to climate change
increased flooding and sea level rise
will put pressure on current
infrastructure
our council has poured over their data
and have some concerns of our own
the main ones include equity for rate
payers the government proposal doesn't
compensate the council for a transfer of
assets valued at 602 million
the accuracy of the government's data
they're promising significant
efficiencies and better affordability
our data paints a different picture
connection to the community waimakariri
would become part of an entity that
covers most of the south island with a
complicated governance arrangement it's
unlikely residents would have a strong
say or influence in local matters
responsiveness during disasters the
canterbury floods earlier this year
showed the value of local knowledge and
having boots on the ground to respond
it's possible a whole of south island
entity may struggle to achieve this
we're also concerned about how this
reform would interact with upcoming
local government changes how this new
entity would appropriately plan for
growth and have concerns about the short
window given to councils to make an
informed decision
so what do you think
the first question to start us off this
evening
why are we asking the community for
their feedback this one is for you dan
well thank you uh firstly we all agree
that um quality drinking water and
environmental outcomes are a good thing
for the country at the moment it's not
clear whether the proposed reforms are
the best way to achieve this and what
the advantages are for our district
this was all triggered by the compiler
bacteria outbreak in heblock north in
2016
which has resulted in new legislation
and a new regulator
as part of this the government are
proposing
to move to water to a move to water
services from councils
and communities to four large entities
across new zealand
there are a number of objectives they
are wanting to achieve and the number of
concerns that the council has on the
community's behalf
the three waters reform proposal is
complex and could have far-reaching
consequences for our community
it is disappointing that the
government's advertising campaign on
three waters
shows sludge coming out of shower heads
and sludge and waterways
i want to assure our community that this
is not the case
we are proud of what we have achieved in
waimakariri we have worked hard to make
sure that we are providing safe drinking
water and are dealing with wastewater
responsibly
we've invested over 100 million dollars
in the last 20 years
and have a 30-year infrastructure
strategy
that is why we are asking our community
what they think
we are not convinced that our ratepayers
will benefit from this change
it's very important to myself and the
councillors that we give our rate payers
a chance to have their say and tonight
is part of that exercise
great thank you dan
and the next question is is the
waimakariri district council doing a
good job delivering three water services
and jared if you could answer this one
for us
yeah thanks nikola um
look the council over the last 20 years
has invested heavily in our three waters
infrastructure and services
we've got around about 600 million
dollars of three waters assets
and in the last 20 years we've spent
more than 100 million dollars
uh carrying out upgrades to that
infrastructure
um it's actually about 29 of the
council's total assets on our books so
it's a
a pretty important piece of
infrastructure
and we do a lot of work to make sure we
manage that well and provide a good
service um just looking forward in our
long term plan we've got 41 million
dollars predicted to suspend and
budgeted for over the coming 10 years
and that's to continue with the good
work that we're doing on improving our
services
as well as responding to new standards
as they are coming on board so yet
answer it i i do believe that we are
doing a really good job
great thank you jared
um if reform goes ahead will residents
pay less for water services and jim if
you could answer this one
that's a good question thank you nicola
what we do know is that costs will
increase between now and 2051.
uh whether there's reform or not there
will be increased standards to be met
but i guess the the council's figures
suggest that um
you know a non-inflation-adjusted figure
would be about
908.2051 to meet the drinking water
standards expected then
um and that's um compared to the
government's figures which are 640
if there was reform
and three thousand dollars if there
wasn't so you can see there's quite a
big difference
and a lot of that is to do with the
basically the subsidy that would be be
paid by the waimakariri residents who've
invested heavily in the last few years
not all councils have done that so
our costs will go up greater compared to
others because that'll help subsidise
them
great thank you jim
and what will the proposed reform mean
for residents dan
the reform proposes uh bringing together
three water services uh in new zealand
currently um delivered by 67 different
councils into four
large entities
if the reform goes ahead the waimakariri
district will become part of an entity
that covers
pretty much most of the south island
excluding part of the top
under the reform proposals councils are
the owners of the entity on behalf of
the communities
there is a no shareholding and there is
no financial recognition of ownership in
the model proposed
a regional representative group of 12
which is made up of six local authority
and six mana whenua appointees would
appoint an independent panel that
selects the board
members for each entity
these board members would govern the
entity and appoint a chief executive who
will manage the staff
on behalf of the entity
the proposed reform could result in less
connection to local decision makers and
mean our community has less of a say in
how three water services are provided
the loss of local connection
and local decision making is a major
concern for our councils and we just
need to think of local examples like the
earthquakes and the recent floods
the critical information that comes from
our local staff makes a difference in
how we respond so the local aspect of it
is a real concern to us and being lost
into a into a larger entity and what say
we might have an influencing future
investment on behalf of our district
thank you mayor dan
and the next question is where are we at
in the process and what are the next
steps
jim
thank you nicola the
at the current stage there is a proposal
for the four entities that mayor dan
mentioned that councils have been asked
to consider and give their feedback to
the government by the end of september
the government will then take those
views into account and decide what the
next steps will be
if we assume that they want to proceed
then the next steps would be for them to
prepare a an amendment to the local
government act to create
these new entities
and that would take place sometime early
next year after cabinet decisions
and then there would be two years of
work to basically
establish these new entities transfer
staff assets and
establish the boards and so on with a
view to them being ready to go and fully
operational
around about mid 2024
and the reason that date has been
selected is my understanding is that
that would then be consistent with the
next 10-year end nlt more than the next
10-year long-term plan for waimakariri
district so that would mean the new
entity would be established at the same
time as we do our next 10-year plan
so that's the current program
it just to stress again the government
has to make that decision it's their
decision not not a council's decision
and part of the feedback from tonight
will be put before the the cabinet
through this process
great thank you jim
now we're going to move on to some of
the questions that have come through
from facebook and youtube and for our
viewers we'll do our best to get to all
of your questions but if you have asked
a question and we don't get to answer it
in this session don't fret we will reply
to you
to your questions online as soon as we
can
we've got a question here from sue and
she's asking how does ecan's
responsibilities sit within the three
waters framework uh jared perhaps you
could answer that one
yeah um so
that's that is a really good question so
um the if you think about the three-watt
each of the three waters separately
um
for and i'll uh so for water supply the
new water regulator um will be
responsible for
potable water that's the water that you
drink from your tap and they will set
the standards for that
um
however ecam will still have a role in
terms of managing the groundwater
resource which is where we draw our
water from so there's i'm still
consenting requirements around
um us extracting water and he can
actually play quite an important role
in managing the land use within the
district which ultimately has an impact
on the groundwater quality
so the next one is storm water so um
in a from a storm water point of view
that's where ecam will continue to have
um very much
largely the same role it has now
the water regulator may have um some
requirements over time that
help guide ecan in terms of the kind of
standards that are to be achieved from
discharges but bchem would continue to
be the consenting authority that we are
answerable to for stormwater um in terms
of wastewater
so that's uh
for us we've got the two main treatment
plants the one
the eastern district scheme and the
oxford wastewater treatment plant uh
currently those are consented by
environment canterbury um
the when the new water regulator comes
in they will actually be setting some
specific discharge
limits that councils need to comply with
so again there'll be a a bit more of a
mixed model there where the regulator
and environment canterbury play a part
great
thank you jared
and andy has asked has the government
given the council all relevant
information on the implications and
requirements relating to three waters
uh dan perhaps you could answer this one
we've received some information i'm not
going to say we've got it all if you go
through the department of internal
affairs website you'll find how
complicated it is we provided
information as required by the end of
last at the end of last year it was then
compilated into
dashboards which were sent to all our
councils which
was a bit of a concern for us because it
was very difficult to try and extract
what the data actually meant
we were concerned that we didn't have
enough information including how the
government arrived at 45 efficiencies
and a number of other claims that were
there in some of the projections and how
our council was placed so we put a
letter to the minister
uh asking 28 questions we've only just
recently received those answers and
we're going through them at the moment
but
i'm i'm advised and our research on it
has shown that we've still got a lot of
gaps in the information the problem with
this process
is that the government's rushing it if
it took its time
worked with the sector more
collaboratively we may have time to
understand all the information and and
what whether the proposal
is going to be good for our community
the moment based on the information
we've seen
we we're
our
our recommendation to the to the
community and certainly our viewers that
we're not seeing this as a proposal that
we would want to progress further with
but it's it's really hard getting that
information and we've engaged the
consultant to help us along with our
professional staff
to try and get the answers together that
we need to provide a position to
government on what our feedback would be
by the end of september really tight
time frames and a real rush and a real
concern that we've been
being asked to come to these decisions
so quickly
the other point
there dan is
we're being asked to respond to one
proposal to solve the problem
and earlier on there was modeling done
of nine different scenarios including
13 if you like new entities in the north
island and five in the south island
which would be
more closely aligned to say the
canterbury region and the case of
waimakariri which may have been if we if
there is to be reform with more of a
private sector type approach to
delivering water then maybe that
warranted further investigation but
there simply hasn't been
time to look at the modeling to go
through what that might mean and work up
alternatives
and it just further to that our concern
around the the pace but we sent a letter
on behalf of the
part of the canterbury mural forum last
week where we've asked the government to
press the pause button so there is
adequate time to consider this in the
context of the water regulator
the government is
in the final stages of introducing and
we shouldn't underestimate the powers of
the water regulator which are immense
they can require councils to make the
investment if they don't feel it's
making that investment and we think that
there needs to be that time taken for
the water regulator to embed first and
then perhaps have a look at other
options as jim was saying that we used
to be funded on the basis of a
deprivation scale and and nzta has a
it's a particularly good funding model
that we are quite used to and how we
work now there's a whole lot of
different models that we think our
sector would welcome the opportunity of
further exploring rather than the one
option that was presented to us at the
end without
proper analysis of the other choices
which may well have been to advantage to
us
thanks dan and jim
uh victor says isn't this just another
step to privatisation of water keep it
local perhaps jim you could respond
well the the proposal is that if the act
was passed that listed in the back of
the act would be a schedule of
all of the owners which would be every
local authority in new zealand that
currently
looks after the three waters
normally an owner has
direct rights of appointment and
replacement to directors and all those
sorts of things
but because of the the complicated
structure to separate out balance sheets
um then that's that's not proposed to
happen
the government has addressed that
proposal by suggesting that the regional
committee i'll just get the name right
the the entity called the regional
representative group which
will have
the six local authority representatives
on it and six from mana whenua
if there was to be any privatisation 75
of those members would have to agree
that was something worth considering
then there would have to be a referenda
in the case of us for most of the south
island
on that subject and 75
of people voting and the entity would
have to agree as well
so
in that sense the government believes
that's a very high bar to essentially
reduce the opportunity for privatization
but it still could potentially happen if
those thresholds were met with the way
that the entities drafted at the moment
thank you jim
cass has asked can wdc afford a 20-year
plus forecast for maintenance upkeep and
upgrades as required for all three areas
jared could you answer this for us
yes yeah look at that that's a really
good question so
we actually
project out our
asset renewals and our operations out
150 years believe it or not
and when we're doing our infrastructure
strategy
so the reason we do that is because a
lot of our assets are very long life and
when we bury a pipe in the ground um we
really don't want to go back and look at
that for another 100 years um
so we actually have done a lot of work
and we do this as part of
our statutory requirements and also
because we think it makes really good
sense to um predict that so we have a
30-year infrastructure strategy um and
it's available in our website and that's
a really good read actually
if you've got the time and that shows
how we're it just shows some of that
modelling we do in that forecasting
um we have a 10-year plan as well so
that just looks at things in a more fine
grained and i talked before about the 41
million we had
um so that sort of level of expenditure
you can expect that we would have to
continue to
do that um
we know our waste water
discharge consent for our ocean outfall
is due around the mid
2030s and we're already starting to
think about how do we position ourselves
to make sure that we're ready for when
that comes and we can achieve the
discharge consent requirements
in terms of drinking water we're
actually really fortunate in this
district
all
every single person who's now on a
waimaker district council water supply
is drinking from a source that
completely complies with the new zealand
drinking water standards so we've
upgraded all of our schemes
to
the point that each of those sources
meets the standards and it's very good
water quality source we've got we've got
deep artesian groundwater on most
schemes
and
the we've actually got money budgeted in
a long-term plan to
achieve increased treatments so that
that includes putting uv treatment on
all of that water if required by the
regulations um and
if we are obliged to which may well come
one day uh there is funding there for
putting chlorine on um
and the uh so and in terms of our
stormwater and wastewater we've forecast
out based on what we anticipate to be
the
regulatory regime we'll be in and
so so far today if you look back over
the last 20 years we've carried out
quite substantial upgrades
while keeping that rates at a reasonably
manageable level and also
catering for the huge amount of growth
we've had in the district and we we
predict the amount of growth out into
the future as well so yes we do believe
we have um forecast for those costs and
are able to cover them
great thank you jared there's certainly
a lot of work going on in the in the
behind the scenes
uh catherine would like to know how uh
do the proposals potentially have
different impacts on the range of water
wastewater and sewerage supplies
throughout the district
for example those that are council
assets and those that are privately
owned or operated
jared back to you for this one
sure yeah look um
there's actually three different parts
to the whole water reform
um and the first one is the setting up
the regulator so that's tomato roi so
that's the regulator that sets the
standards for um water supply and
there's actually the water services bill
going through at the moment and that
that actually talks about the
regulations so that's the second part so
what what the rules are um and what are
what are the rules that the regulator
needs to enforce so though for the both
of those our council is actually quite
supportive um
and we see a lot of it makes a lot of
sense to have a regulator um there'll
also be an economic regulator in the
future and again we um we'd be really
pleased to see that uh come in so from
uh from that side of things what that
means is for all of the council water
supplies
we'll be required to comply with that
um there's two other kinds of water
supplies in the district so there's
people who are on individual wells so if
you've just got one well or one water
supply that just serves one house
they're not actually impacted on by the
what's happening
at this stage
but there are a lot of schemes we know
in the district um where there might be
two or more households connected to one
well and they will get caught up in that
regulation and the requirements of the
regulator um and some of those are quite
um big schemes there's up to 60 people
on on some but but there are we do know
and we're quite aware there's quite a
number of people who are on lifestyle
blocks where they might be sharing a
well amongst one two or a handful of
properties they will need to comply with
the new standards um and be answerable
to the
water regulator
so
so that's that's that part of it that so
the third part of the reform is what
we're actually consulting on now and
that's the whether or not these water
entities um and whether you know we
think that's a good thing for that
council
um
those water the water entities is more
about transferring council assets over
and on top of all of that if there's any
um schemes who
struggle there are some of those private
schemes
if they struggle to
meet the standards
there is the possibility that um the
dominant entity um
in the area which was would either be
the council or the regulator
may have a role in those being
transferred over to them at some point
in the future that's still subject um to
being worked through the water services
bill so um we're not 100 sure whether
where the government's going to land on
that one at this stage and it's probably
also worth just if you take a look back
um over time in this district we've
actually extended our public water
supplies out to service areas that are
in the past we're served on individual
wells and a good example of that is
um where we extended the water supply
out there because of water quality
issues so it's likely that over time
there would be um some people who are
currently on private wells and and
whether they are in areas that are
running out of water or um
because of low ground water or there's
water quality issues all this growth
that happens um in that area there's
whether it whether the water is being
serviced by the council or a um the one
of these large entities in the future
there's a possibility that some of those
schemes will continue to be connected up
to public supplies over time
great thank you jared uh shane has asked
just how many councils in new zealand
are struggling to meet the three water
standard jim maybe you can answer this
one
um i don't have a hard statistic but um
you know there's
my feeling is is probably about half and
half
the smaller councils um it's a it's a
bigger hurdle for them to meet the
standards because they just don't have
as many rate payers
um and that's why um when the if the
reforms happen
um a lot of the the smaller rate payer
entities will be the people will be
better off but perhaps mia dan might
have a closer feel for that
um being in touch with the mayors
through new zealand
i thought
that there are a number of councils that
for sure look no one's arguing that um
there doesn't need to be change and in
fact and talking to colleagues
throughout the country most and their
long-term plans are projecting fairly
well significant expenditure there
but what
putting them into four entities
throughout new zealand is not
necessarily going to fix the problems
that there are and that's what our some
of us have been talking about well if
you actually took the money the
government proposing around 2.5 billion
dollars put that into a fund you could
actually work directly with those
councils that are struggling uh to to
meet those costs and and look for for
instance in our community we found a way
that we kind of
managed that cost and and we've been
talking about the potential of joining
our water suppliers up and having a
district-wide rate we haven't quite made
that decision yet that was something we
put off until the to the next year but
that's a way we were looking at
potentially how we could manage some of
those costs that that were there and
we've been managing that in terms of
some of the upgrades that we've been
doing
and uh for instance points right as a
prime example of that
uh where there's some uh subsidy coming
from throughout the district to help uh
that small rural supply with that
upgrade so on a similar basis the
government could do the same and target
the likes of uh
for instance the chatham islands which
really does struggle uh with meeting the
standards and also the costs there's a
whole range of ways that this could be
done and it used to be done that way it
was called it was funded on the
deprivation scale basis
uh and uh we we managed jared i'm sure
you'll remember to get some funding
there for the oxford community at that
time exactly the size and scale of it
i'm i'm not entirely clear from all
councils but you know no one's going to
say that we're not without challenges
and there aren't things but that's where
you have adequate planning and as our
council has we've got a 30-year
infrastructure strategy
with double a rated as a council by
standard of double a with a plus rating
from standard and pause for a financial
rate
management but also double a rated by
local government new zealand for the
sort of council we are on an excellence
program so we've got that program well
managed and for other councils there are
other ways of doing this rather than a
one-size-fits-all which is what the
government is proposing
thank you mayor dan
we've had some concerns raised about the
new shared governance and the role of
manafenoua what are your thoughts on
this governance model back to you dan
ah
look i
i'm not sold on the governance model
i'll be honest with you um
and
look we've been working
behind the scenes we've been having
conversations with with naita who are
about those opportunities and and let's
be hon
that they're very keen to be partners uh
in the naitahitakiwara as it's called in
the governance structure look if i look
back and why and be a carryout council
so we actually involve manufa right now
we have um
a
a local um we meet on a runaway liaison
group which we meet regularly and
principally the conversations are about
water we're answerable to the aunties
who are frankly a wonderful group but
their principal concern is making sure
that we have good water with looking
after our waterways and dealing with
things responsibly we also have a
mahitahi committee so from a manafenuwa
position that has three representatives
of naito naito hariri and three from our
council we we actually have that model
in place right now increased manafenua
representation i know is a concern for
a number of people on what's proposed
but
this is a proposal that's come from
government it hasn't come from the
councils
and they're very determined that that
will be the model that does go for that
has manafino a representation i'm not
afraid as i said here
of ewe involvement as we do now
because it's important that we talk to
all our community about what the
priorities are
just too much of that something
yes just broadening it a little bit the
the reason we're told is for the
complicated
structure which basically has this
regional group
that regional group appoints an
appointments committee
uh
and that appointments committee appoints
the directors to the new company
so you've got three layers in there
whereas at the moment there's one
there's your counsellors who are making
the decisions and you can talk to them
directly the reason we're told it needs
to be this way is to create a distance
between the owners local authorities and
the entities doing the work so that
standard and poors and other rating
agencies can
appropriately rate them and they can
therefore borrow
the funds that are going to be necessary
to deal with the 120 to 180 billion
dollar deficit over the next 50 years to
bring water free waters up to standard
but we haven't actually cited any of the
correspondence between the government
and their advisors and these agencies
and supposedly if this happens
local authorities that are left without
three waters will also be able to borrow
more to deal with whatever they want to
for social infrastructure and so on so
it seems from a council perspective
anyway that you're a lot further away
from where you are now in terms of
making decisions around service levels
funding and so on which this new model
would basically put in the hands of
the boards with
consultation requirements on them
and that is our concern as i said
earlier there's no
there's no direct representative that we
can see that would ensure our local
democracy is continued and where our
locals say would be as you do with the
council now
we're accountable as a council to to our
ratepayers directly we go out and
consult regularly what we're really
concerned is that loss of localism in
this model
and what priority it would come
if it came to a decision around
expenditure how would how would our
priorities be taken into account and be
adequately considered
we do that now
and we balance that against all our
decisions about what their priorities
are in consultation with our community
not clear how that would end up under
that under the proposed structure
thank you both
uh rebecca wants to know does the
council's budget allow for the cost of
climate change adaption to 2050 and does
it allow for the cost of likely tighter
regulation on nitrate levels jared could
you answer this for us
yes yeah i'm happy to answer that i mean
they really are two really good
questions thank you uh rebecca um
perhaps i'll tackle the nitrate one
first um
we uh it is something we're very
conscious of and the issue with nitrates
has been quite a
big part of our decision making around
some of our smaller water supplies so
we've recently connected up the points
road water supply
to the west eaton water supply and one
of the drivers for that was we were
concerned about the nitrate levels on
the
points road
scheme
it was uh it was getting too close for
our like liking um to the trigger levels
and the drinking water standards
um so we're uh
so in terms of nitrates we're now
getting most of our water um
i'd probably go as far as about 99
percent of it from very deep aquifers
that um to date have not had any issues
with nitrates
when you look out over a one sort of a
thing like a 100-year window
some of the work that has been done by
environment canterbury does show that
there is a potential
risk to
those very deep aquifers now that's
being managed
by the rural sector and um through the
regional plan that environment canada
and canterbury do
so and there's also a lot more work and
modeling going into trying to get a much
better understanding of that so it's
very unlikely that it's going to become
an issue for us a large issue for us
our water treatment that we do um
on a lot of our scans we actually don't
need to do any water treatment
but if we were to require to do that it
would be quite some time out well beyond
2050 and it's actually
with all of the um land use activity and
and the changes in the rural sector
we're hoping that that actually never
eventuates that
nitrates are managed at the source
rather than becoming an issue for future
generations um look if it does there are
ways of treating water to manage it and
they can't they actually it can be quite
expensive
um so the short answer is we've we've
got that in hand um it's something we're
monitoring um and we don't see that
there's going to be affordability issue
for our district with regard to nitrates
um climate change
we've been thinking about climate change
for a long time so um
and we're we're currently spending about
20 million dollars in kaiapoi um
upgrading the stormwater infrastructure
so we're putting in some quite large um
trunk stormwater upgrades so part of the
driver for that is all is not only
managing
the issues we've got at the moment but
it's actually to help
provide some protection for kaya puya
against climate change
we've modeled
all of our flood mapping has an
allowance for increase in rainfall we've
allowed for increased storm surge at the
coast at a higher sea level
so we're really thinking about it so
everything that's been built into our
long-term plan and our infrastructure
strategy does make allowance for climate
change um
and
but it is one of these things that's
about that is evolving over time and no
matter what happens whether it's the
council or the um you know a large
entity it's going to come more and more
to the fore in our district particularly
for the low-lying and coastal
communities um
and that that is something that the
council will definitely be engaging with
the community um out into the future but
from a infrastructure point of view yes
we're we're planning for it we're
predicting and
uh and starting to budgets for it as
well
you can't just say that from a political
level
climate change is a is a really
important issue for the council we are
in the process and we have a climate
change strategy and we're working our
way through that
can we do more of course there's lots
more we can do but we're trying to
adequately plan as jared's mentioning
we're also working together with our
partner councils including environment
canterbury i personally chair
uh the canterbury mural forum climate
change group and it's looking at
information across our different
councils because if we're to to work on
this it's something that we've actually
got to work on across canterbury in fact
across new zealand uh because it's a
really important issue but at a local
level when i was elected
i wanted to signal the importance of
climate change and i pointed a council
to a councillor to the role of climate
change and sustainability um to signal
the importance of that and the council
that's leading that's doing a really
good job we've got lots more work we are
going to do in that space
but we are starting with earnest but as
jared said we're planning from an
infrastructural perspective but also
broader than that what our response will
be but working in at a regional level
and also at a national level
thanks jared and mia dan
uh richard wants to know do the council
have alternative options for reform of
three waters or prefer to continue with
status quo
jim would you like to answer
this i think that's probably a better
question for the mayor
look i
i'm happy to give that a go
um look at the present time we we we are
saying that that from our council's
perspective the status quo adequately
addresses where we're at because we've
made it clear that we've we've got
things uh
under control and managed but from a
regional perspective we're really happy
to work and then look at alternatives
and i've mentioned a couple that we've
been considering and what's what we're
saying to the government press the pause
get let the water regulator get in place
get it established then let's see where
we go and there's a number of options
including the nine scenarios that
the ceo mentioned earlier that the
government had had been considering i
mentioned the earlier around the
deprivation scale for instance that's
one way that the central pot could be
put aside and councils could apply to
that or a co-funding model like nzta
heaven place which we that's their
transport authority
and uh for instance we get 50 50 funding
uh on our roads and but we go into a bid
process for that at a national level i
think that and then number of mural
colleagues throughout the country and
councils think that's a good option to
explore where you could look at the
co-funding and then look at the likes of
the chathams for instance or other
communities which are struggling and
they may get
funding on a higher basis which is what
happens now with the ncta funding so a
co-funding model is something we
certainly think can be explored but
we've actually been working
uh on a regional basis anyway of looking
how we can share our services and work
together more effectively and that's
something that will continue regardless
of the reform discussion those those
discussions are happening now but from
our perspective we're not seeing
for our district that there that the
model is put forward or uh other than
the status quo of advantage to us at the
moment but we're open-minded to what
other future potentials may be developed
as long as the government allows us to
have that
to keep that decision
and make that choice ourselves
thank you dan
and we're hearing concerns about
chlorine being added to water supplies
and could jarrod you talk to this one
yeah look that's a really important
issue for our district
and that is something that the new um
water services bill will introduce as an
issue that'll um and it's already it's
already come up as an issue for us um
so
the vast majority of our urban schemes
do not get chlorinated
at the moment and when we have surveyed
our communities in the past we've had
very strong feedback
our community tell us they don't want
chlorine in the water on the whole
there are some people in our community
who do but
certainly based on the feedback we get
uh the majority of people prefer to have
their water without chlorine
so um
and we're very fortunate to be in a
position to be able to do that
because of the good quality of our
groundwater that we get
so the new
regulations will actually
make it compulsory for councils or
anyone supplying water
to chlorinate um they call it residual
disinfection but that just means
chlorine really um
and unless they get an exemption from
the regulator um now that is something
we're trying to work and we're working
closely with our neighbors and so when
in christchurch because they also have
the same facing the same issue they have
a strong desire to to provide a
non-chlorinated supply as their
community expect
and so we're being quite proactive in
that working together with them and we
want to really proactively engage with
the water regulator as soon as they are
up and running um and we've already
initiated
some level of conversation there
so that will be an issue for us um
i don't believe any um council in new
zealand has managed to get a water
safety plan approved without chlorine
just in the last year or two since this
has become such an issue um and that
puts us in that camp as well um so it
will come to the head for us um
very soon and that and and it's
important to note that's going to be an
issue regardless of
whether um
it's a
a bigger entity or your or your local
council who currently provides the water
um and that may be something that you
know in the feedback um we're expecting
people if you've got a view on
if these entities do stand up um
let us know what you you know whether
you want to have the ability for as a
community to still um look for that
level of service where you don't have
chlorine because there will be
additional
requirements that we're going to have to
do going into the future to be able to
continue to provide that non-chlorinated
water
and jared rightly observes that
chlorination is a big issue for our
community we
uh he and i both flew to wellington in
front of the select committee on the
water services bill and put this case
very strongly on behalf of our community
because we know how
important it is that's why we've made
the investment and deep source aquifers
over in making sure that we're providing
good drinking water and also that we
have been investigating alternatives
like uv disinfection
so you know we have applied for it for
an exemption and we will keep fighting
hard on or advocating hard on the
subject because we know how important it
is for our community but
in the hands of a of a um
a new water entity
not sure what say we'd have over there
that's one of the risks and ultimately
as jared says the government legislate
for it um through a and we and the water
regulator make that decision
what choice we will have apart from
strong advocacy which is what we will
always do on behalf of our ratepayers
thank you both and we just got a couple
more questions uh cass is interested to
know is council concerned with the
upcoming rma reforms affecting this
process and decision
uh jim perhaps over to you
that's an excellent question thank you
um the rma reforms
essentially
um are going to result in a regionalized
approach to a new spatial plan for
canterbury and then the natural built
environment act which will essentially
have the the rules for land use and
again
the uh the proposition is that that will
be prepared at a regional level
so you can sort of see a natural fit
between
a smaller number of water entities and a
regional approach to planning because
one of the crucial things here is the
alignment of our planning to the
infrastructure requirements and at the
moment
that's relatively easy for the council
to do
so our district planners and our
long-term planners and spatial planning
people work closely with jarrod and his
team around the infrastructure and
getting the timing right along with
developers so with the rma reforms
potentially being much set at a regional
level then that responsiveness to
the infrastructure needs and the
provision and the timing could be a
challenge
but also if these entities water
entities were created there would have
to be very strong linkages written into
them to formally participate in our
district planning processes even if it
is at a regional level
so
mia dan mentioned earlier about the
canterbury mayor's writing to the
minister of local government suggesting
there'd be a pause
essentially to allow all the reforms to
catch up because if you were doing it in
a logical sequence you would come up
with a future for local government
direction then you bring in the planning
direction and then you bring in the
infrastructure direction but we're
almost doing it the other way around
three waters reform first planning
second and then finally the future for
local government so
there's there needs to be some greater
work done to align
wherever the rma reforms are going with
the water reforms as a minimum and
ideally see it in the context of the
future for local government and i'm
pretty sure mayor dan will have a view
on this one as well
i think jim's very adequately
articulated that the the future for
local government discussion should have
happened first or should be happening
now
uh
actually rma reform as jim rightly
mentions has potentially got huge
consequences so it's the speed and pace
of this reform program that's happening
right at the moment that we are saying
there just needs to be a breather let's
catch up let's get the water regulator
in place future for local government
conversation then we can start to think
about where we're placed in that so we
can adequately consider the timing of
all this proposed change and what
response we can give at speed of it at
the moment that really concerns us
because there's only so much you can do
to keep up with all that
and water reforms on top of it it's just
not adequate time to to properly
consider and the government brought
forward the reform program
uh what was to be a conversation that we
were expecting to hear probably by
december we were advised uh back in july
that we were needing to have an advanced
conversation and give a position by the
end of september
um which
we just weren't prepared for so that's
why we're out with this conversation
we've got the material out the best
information we've got because we wanted
to have that conversation with our
community and set your view
so that we can adequately re represent
that opinion to government when required
to by the end of september
thanks dan
and caitlin wants to know what is the
opinion of other councils are there more
in support or against and perhaps dan
again back to you
i think there's a growing concern around
council there's certainly some councils
that do support the reform program
but the the growing view amongst
councils at the moment is that they're
disappointed with the government's
advertising campaign they're
disappointed with the speed and pace of
the reform
and what they're asking for in the
message of canterbury mural forum is
actually followed through a number of
councils who are saying let's press the
pause let's give them time to consider
it let the water regulator in place as
we've said and see what happens from
there
but no to wait there's not a united view
amongst councils and local government
new zealand are certainly
pushing for the reform conversation
but majority a number of councils that i
talk to are certainly concerned about it
and
want the whole process slowed down so we
can adequately consider it
but there will be councils that some
will benefit from it and some won't and
we're one of the councils that has
actually performed really well in that
space so we're not seeing
a benefit for us apart from
potentially subsidising other councils
which haven't performed but there are
other models as we've talked about
and those other councils i'm talking to
all the time would rather have that
conversation openly and consider what
those alternatives are before we're
stuck with a conversation about four
entities which is effectively where the
government's at the moment
thank you dan we're almost out of time
so if you have asked a question that we
didn't manage to get to this evening
don't worry we will reply online after
the session but before we go mayor dan
why is it important that people give us
their feedback
look it's really important to hear what
our residents have to say for us and to
be informed by that and that's why we've
gone ahead with this exercise of going
out with the survey that we posted to
you
or that you can fill the survey in
online the link
if you want to do that online is
waimakariri.gabt.nz forward slash let's
talk
by doing this the council will be well
informed and that we can give
waimakari's feedback to the government
it's really important that we hear your
views on this and that's why we put
together this conversation tonight to
inform you
if you've still got questions we welcome
uh you're you're contacting us directly
so we can answer those or fill in the
chat and we'll do our best to get that
information back to you but we really
welcome that feedback and your views the
survey closes
on september the 5th
so please do get your view in before
then
after that the council will
finalize what feedback that we will give
to the government at a special meeting
on the 28th of september after this
we'll be back in touch with you with
what the next steps are that we will be
uh considering in this process
can i just say nicolas we're coming to a
close just
thanks to all of you
who have showed an interest tonight and
for the questions that you've put
forward
we hope you find
and have found it useful to you and it's
helped inform you better to give us your
feedback can i think say thanks
particularly to jim and jared
and um to you nicola zariam so you've
done an excellent job keeping us online
and making sure that
we're keeping to time with the questions
to everyone out there take care thank
you
thanks very much dan and so that's all
we have time for tonight
if you want to know more or if you have
some feedback on what we've discussed
tonight visit the let's talk page and
let us know and that web address again
is
waimakariri.govt dot nz forward slash
let's talk
so thanks very much to our panel and
thanks so much to you at home for
joining us stay safe and have a great
evening
[Music]
you